[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to quickly cover
some new information about the recently
announced hogwarts tournament of houses
an upcoming harry potter tv show but
before we get into it further i want to
clarify that this show should not be
confused with the harry potter 20th
anniversary and cast reunion entitled
harry potter return to hogwarts
coming january 1st this show with the
full working title of harry potter
hogwarts tournament of houses is a bit
of a new concept for you see it's a quiz
show the trailer was released at the end
of last month on october 28th one month
in advance of the show's scheduled
release november 28th and it gave us the
first proper glance of what's to come
the show which will be hosted by helen
mirren is going to feature special guest
stars and enchanting prizes as
contestants answer wizarding world
questions for their hogwarts house and
compete against each other an article
published on wizarding world continues
revealed in today's trailer the quiz
show will be awash with special guest
stars including harry potter cast
members tom felton simon fisher becker
shirley henderson luke youngblood
alongside other cameos from the likes of
saturday night livestar pete davidson
and comedian jay leno both
self-confessed harry potter fans the
competition will take the shape for
bracket style game where fans compete
for their hogwarts house in teams of
three the houses will go head to head in
three special episodes gryffindor vs
hufflepuff will be the first with the
winning team advancing to the grand
finale alongside the glory of winning
for their hogwarts house a huge roster
of prizes will be on offer for the
contestants such as a 1 000 shopping
spree at the harry potter new york store
tickets to the broadway production of
harry potter and the cursed child
advanced screenings for fantastic beasts
the secrets of dumbledore and much more
helen mirren who is hosting the event
seemed to express extreme delight about
her involvement with the production i
knew someday i'd get a harry potter role
and i'm so pleased to take part in the
20-year film celebration said mirin the
films inspired such enchantment and
wonder for so many of us and it will be
such a treat to reignite that magic for
the countless fans who continue to revel
in this spellbinding world
are you guys excited for this it'll be
dropping in just a few days on november
28th comment down below and please
remember to like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]